entre féministes je résume la faire le
sujet de l'émission était la liberté
d'expression et d'opinion en france
les invités ont abordé les différentes
affaires de viol relaté dans les médias
dernièrement et c'est là que les
échanges se sont tendus
alain finkielkraut a critiqué la notion
de culture du viol dans notre société et
à dénoncer le politiquement correct
il a conclu son propos comme suit
monsieur finkielkraut le message que
vous envoyez à toutes les petites filles
ont été violées
d'ailleurs je viole la mène tous les
soirs n'avez pas le droit de dire ça
alors ça c'est la séquence qui circule
depuis ce matin sur les réseaux sociaux
mais voici là même le contexte en plus
on marie bigard texte ou cyril hanouna
ne peuvent pas ignorer que quand ils
tiennent ce genre de propos il banalise
de fait les violences quand on dit
qu'une fille de 13 ans violée par un
réalisateur en l'occurrence polanski
s'est dit désolé sexualité avec
l'actualité
jeudi quand vous dites ça monsieur
finkielkraut le message que vous envoyez
à toutes les petites filles
d'ailleurs je viens la mène tous les
soirs n'avez pas le droit de dire je n'y
passe t il a dérapé alain finkielkraut
n'a pas dérapé et s'est énervé il ay la
raisonner par l'absurde en faisant de
l'ironie ça peut être déplacé il peut
être pas à son meilleur dans ce genre de
débat télévisé sur 1,6 ou
en effet il perd un peu son calme mais
il y aurait qu il ya de quoi perdre son
calme devant caroline de haas et je le
comprends et je pense que c'est alors il
ya deux choses
il ya d'une part ce que trouve cette
émission c'est que la culture du débat
en effet en france est compliqué c'est à
dire que c'est devenu un au point que
voilà le lite et enfin on ne prend
toutes les choses de manière littérale
c'est à dire que le second degré
l'humour est pris avec lui alors on ne
sait pas si la mauvaise foi si elles
pensent véritablement qu'il a appris au
viol auquel cas bon c'est officiel si
elle pense réellement qu'il appelait au
violon né ont aussi entre la bêtise et
la mauvaise foi avec deux cas moi je
pense assez inquiétant et après sur le
fond en effet il ya cette espèce de
cette notion de culture du viol
qu'emploient les féministes pour
finalement criminaliser tout discours
contraire et critique du féminisme
radical est problématique
on peut très bien critiquer le continuum
qu'on fait entre la galanterie et le
viol sans s'adonner à la culture du gun
et participé à l'écriture du viol mais
on peut très bien faire des blagues sur
parce que les blagues d'humour depuis
toujours enfin un humour un peu noir
d'ailleurs son appel du mont noir c'est
de rigoler sur des choses qui sont pas
drôles parce que si on rigole que sur
des choses qui sont drôles et bien c'est
pas très drôle en fait et donc oui oui
effectivement
et quand blanche gardin fait des
sketches où elle rigole en effet de ces
situations de sexisme machin c'est drôle
parce que justement c'est des sujets
graves et ccsa l'humour noir et en fait
de criminaliser toute forme d'humour
toute forme de discours critique de
distancier je sais c'est vraiment un
étouffement la liberté expression
discutons arguments contre arguments et
la notion de culture de viol mais mérite
de critiquer et ce que je reproche à des
féministes c'est à dire que l es là ni
lit toute possibilité de critique
puisqu'elle intègre la critique à leur
propre idéologie c'est à dire que si
vous les critiquez c'est que vous même
vous donnant lecture du golfe qui
critiquaient la culture du viol s'est
faite apologie d'actes aucun débat n'est
possible c'est cap en ce que karl popper
appelé le les algues enfin l'idéologie
c'est à dire quand on ne peut pas
falsifié les arguments mais c'est qu'on
est dans l'idéologie il n'y a pas de
débat possible et c'est
et ce en était la preuve que vous êtes
d'accord levy je vois hocher la tête
je suis totalement d'accord avec passes
tes jeux chez la tête en regardant la
réaction de catherine ii et à ce qui est
franchement caroline pardon de masse
parce que franchement dans le pays de la
liberté d'expression le pays qui a vu
des millions de gens défiler dans les
rues après l'attentât contre charlie
hebdo où on défend justement ce celle de
la démocratie qui est le sarcasme
l'ironie le deuxième degré j'ai
l'impression et je m'inquiète que la
france soit en train de perdre un des
selles ses atouts les plus fondamentaux
et ceux qui nous ont toujours chez lui
partout en europe c'est à dire cette
capacité aussi dorée aujourd'hui tout
est dit de façon trop martial solennel
il ya un débat vraiment très tendu
faudrait vraiment récupérer un petit peu
d'ironie et d'apaisement déjà et de
légèreté l'ironie semences il faut pas
être léger c'est trop grave non mais un
peu de légèreté c'est pas dire on va au
sérieux c'est une business unit qui va
faire des politiques publiques sérieuse
sur ces sujets mais c'est assez ses
militants doivent bannir toute légèreté
de l'espace public c'est richard des
vous êtes d'accord un peu de légèreté
talibans on va un autre point de vue fin
j'ai envie de partir de desproges on
peut rire de tout mais pas avec
n'importe qui et peut-être pas n'importe
où moi c'est déjà le format ces
émissions qui commence un peu à
interroger parce que c'est des formats
d'émissions qui sont pas du tout fait
pour débattre qui sont des des objets en
fait à fabriquer du buzz à fabriquer du
clash et à un moment donné ces émissions
on voit bien qu'elle dérape et que un
type de discours qui pourrait très bien
passé dans d'autres émissions passent
pas du tout là le deuxième degré
qu'invoque alain finkielkraut
franchement il saute pas aux yeux
foncièrement ce qui saute aux yeux est à
l'oreille plus exactement c'est que
quand il dit ça on a du mal à voir
quelques routes comme étant un apôtre du
viol dont il ya un truc qui va pas par
contre quand il dit qu'il est au
deuxième degré la manière dont il le dit
franchement le deuxième degré n'apparaît
pas spontanée par contre qu apparaissent
ces carreaux face à caroline delas qui
est en mode jeu l'asticot john asticote
et qu'elle va provoquer quelque part le
fait qu'ils sortent de ses gonds à un
moment donné mais c'est le format de
cette émission d'abord ma que j'ai envie
d'interroger ensuite c'est un débat
entre caroline de haas et alain
finkielkraut tel qu'il est organisé
parce qu'on passe de
paul 11 qui a tout fait c'est quand même
un du tout et n'importe quoi force est
vraiment il ya tout dedans et est donc
cette réaction là que je l'avais en
regard de quoi regarde je ne pense
absolument pas que ce soit la pensée
d'alain je lui fais vraiment je pense
que je pense que c'est une phrase qui
dit aux 2e 3e 4e degré mais je pense que
ça ne passe pas ça ne passe pas et comme
après les réseaux sociaux sont presque
plus important que l'émission elle-même
dans ce qui va en être fait la petite
séquence qui est passé en maintenant
notre sentiment d'un un sentiment qu'il
était mort donc c'est vrai que c'est moi
je trouve que dans cette histoire
en fait oui il faudrait plus de légèreté
probablement oui il faut de la liberté
d'expression mais dans cette émission là
je ne pense que ça ne passe pas ça ne
passe pas et le débat qu'on a là ne
permet pas entre caroline de haas et
alain finkielkraut qu'alain finkielkraut
soit au second degré et ces deux fêtes
lui au premier degré par une partie je
pense pas partout par une partie est
donc c'est ça que je dénonce dans ce
format d'émission et moi j'ai vu
beaucoup de gens qui interrogeait le csa
sur cette émission mais j'ai aussi envie
d'interroger lci sur ses formes à la
haye ce que les grandes confrontations
c'est obligatoirement le grand guignol
c'est-à-dire un moment donné des gens
finkielkraut et de qualité et qu'on met
dans une émission au format ou sa pensée
en vient à être à ce point acculé à
utiliser des méthodes qui ne sont pas
comprises
en tout cas les internautes du figaro
sont assez partagés puisque bros
nintendo dit on sait très bien qu'il
fait du second degré l'ironie est une
figure de style tout à fait valable et
bien sûr vous êtes vraiment
parallèlement le prendre premier du
second degré où va-t-on voilà ils sont
saouls et le résultat ont posé la
question sur twitter peut-on faire de
deuxième degré sur la question des
violences sexuelles et vous êtes 57% à
nous dire que oui
vous parlez d'actualité justement
richard brumm c'est la question je
voulais en venir à la romaine polanski
est ce que est ce que là où on va pas
trop long c'est justement un petit peu
après quand alain finkielkraut défend
polanski mais justement moi je suis en
désaccord avec la position
voilà je suis en désaccord avec la
position d'alain finkielkraut sur le
même plan de ski mais il faut bien voir
ce qui est en train de se passer
dire qu'il ya une association féministe
appel nous tout qui a découpé les sept
secondes d'alain finkielkraut est en
train de faire de l'ironie et qui est en
train de faire une pétition pour qu'il
soit licencié de france culture donc
soit elles n'ont pas compris c'est de
l'ironie et elles sont profondément
stupide soit deuxième option
elle manipule sciemment ce qui est
évidemment l'ironie pour faire licencier
alain finkielkraut et là c'est
extrêmement inquiétant
je pense qu'elles n'ont jamais entendu
son émission réplique une seule fois
dans leur vie
je pense que c'est sans doute au delà de
leur intelligence le problème c'est que
honda mais honnêtement vraiment c'est
extrêmement grave je dis pas ça pour
refléter au génie bastié mais elle
aurait peut-être pu écouter le débat sur
le féminisme entre génie bastille et
manon garcia organisée par alain
finkielkraut dans réplique mais qui
aimait à dd lieu au dessus de ce qu'elle
pratique comme forme de militantisme et
moi ce qui me ce qui me dérange c'est
que ya pas si longtemps les bien
pensants les offusqués perpétuelle les
donneurs de leçons c'était les gens de
droite un peu catholiques etc et
aujourd'hui les curés sont de gauche
on a vraiment des curés de gauche c'est
des gens ils sont dans une espèce de
pudibonderie progressiste insupportable
leur principale occupation sait compter
le nombre de femmes et minorité sur les
photos pour montrer qu'il ya un problème
c'est vraiment l'équarrissage et c'est
vraiment important qui pose problème
c'est que oui on peut dire que polanski
a pas ne pas être d'accord avec une cote
sur polanski c'est mon cas je pense que
cette note qui devrait être jugé et
qu'il ne doit pas être protégé c'est
autre chose de dire est-ce qu'on peut
regarder ses films ou pas mais la
question aujourd'hui c'est même pas deux
de dire de juger polanski mais de juger
les personnes qui défendent polanski
c'est vrai on aurait pas non seulement
polanski devrait pas faire de film mais
on devrait privé d'antenne les gens qui
défendent pendant ce qu'il veut mais
chassez le prisonnier non mais si oui
c'est ça non mais c'est ça qui était
délirant cette espèce de culture du viol
c'est de dire que finalement c'est un
espèce de dalots de violence symbolique
qui vont de la défense de polanski à la
défense de la galanterie à au sexisme et
c est du coup de police et les paroles
comme police les actes et là je crois
qu'il ya un glissement qui est très
dangereux pour pour le débat public et
la démocratie et cette confusion
systématique entre violence symbolique
et violences physiques qui est
entretenue par une certaine extrême
gauche elle m'apparaît très
problématique pourquoi parce que elle
peut elle conduire à relativiser
relativiser la viola véritable violence
la violence symbolique la violence
physique
le viol les agressions sexuelles qui
sont des violences réelles qui sont pas
des violences de langage et il faut
garder au maximum le maximum de liberté
possible dans le langage et cette idée
de dire que le langage tue les gens qui
films qui vont écouter fines gaules
youtube qui défend polanski et bien ça
va plus c'est des gens à les violer à
les violer les femmes c'est entièrement
faux
c'est en tenant ce genre de raisonnement
on aboutit à une régression la liberté
d'expression et je trouve ça inquiétant
mais ce qui est intéressant ce décès en
rupture du vial je pense que lecture de
la culture du viol je pense qu'à une
barbarie d'une violence et revient
justement qu'il n'ya plus de culture
mais
une acculturation une déculturation une
sauvagerie le viol est une sauvagerie et
la pornographie
moi j'avais passé à la culture la
pornographie l'europe est certes un
certain rap en tout cas très vulgaire
dessins peintures de viola voilà il ya
une sous culture du globe peut-être il
n'y a pas de culture du vieux de la
culture justement c'est ce qui me fait
sortir les cette barbarie de sauvagerie
et des pulsions donc et cette notion de
tueur du viol ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que la société dans son entier
c'est comme le racisme d'état
la société dans son entier pousserait
inculquera des jeunes garçons et les
jeunes hommes à se conduire mal avec les
femmes je crois que c'est faux je crois
que c'est au contraire il n'y a pas
d'éducation pas de culture qu'on bascule
dans la barbarie et donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai beaucoup de mal avec cette
notion et elle doit être être discutée
et critiquer et charles oui vous
partager cette analyse mais ce n'a de
sujet pas du tout en désaccord mais
encore une fois je si je reviens sur la
partie là qu'on évoque puisqu'on est on
est passé de les mêmes nous en fait dans
notre format on zappe à un peu on passe
des propos est ce qu'on peut faire du
second degré à polanski est ce que oui
ou non son film façon film et c'est un
des sujets les spectateurs dans le
spectateur ça veut dire quand même que
ce nom mais c'est à dire que le format
en fait ça me pose quand même aussi un
sujet c'est à dire qu on glisse et on
dit c'est un peu trop facilement sera à
la fois les mots les éléments et moi je
pense en plus sain que dans la séquence
il faut regarder les deux protagonistes
et qu'on a regardé un des protagonistes
plus fortement mais je pense que c'est
le débat qui se crée qui est un non
débat qui est tout sauf du débat qui est
un espèce de moments de clash qui va
arriver entre caroline de haas et d'un
côté et puis alain finkielkraut et qu'
il est à un moment donné il en arrive à
dire cette phrase qui effectivement
sorti de son contexte parce que c'est
comme ça que beaucoup l'ont lu ces
petites secondes sur twitter mais c'est
aussi parfois est le résumé qu'on a eu
simplement dans des dépêches
effectivement qui peut interroger alors
recontextualiser c'est toujours quelque
chose qui est que messi henry roche de
la part du journaliste mais bien sûr
hyérois l'atsa sans dire que c'est de
lire les d'accord on va trouver ça me
bouffe ya pas de permis qui souhaitent
pas osé donc fois encore sur lefigaro.fr
phyllis est d'accord avec vous adrien
puisqu'il dit
l'ennui avec le second degré c'est qu'il
faut un minimum de culture et nicolas
qui nous dit à force de se brider
bientôt l'ironie disparaîtra aussi
voilà vous étiez tous relativement
d'accord sur le sujet on passe du coup à
notre troisième thème ce soir faut-il
subventionner les associations qui
dénonce un racisme d'état
on se pose la question au moment où la
ville de paris s'apprête à renouveler
ses subventions à plusieurs d'entre
elles entre autres la cort l'assemblée
citoyenne des originaires de turquie
alors quand on va sur leur site on peut
lire des tribunes qui commence comme ça
alors c'est en écriture inclusive nous
livre en chasse et torturé traumatisé
persécuté par l'état et le système des
frontières nous habitants des quartiers
populaires harceler humilié au quotidien
par les forces de police est ciblé par
le racisme d'état etc etc
richard good est ce que c'est normal de
distribuer des subventions à des
associations qui tiennent ce genre de
discours
alors je ne vais pas être très cool sur
ce sujet parce que la manière dont il
est abordé me pose un peu problème
d'avoir c'est pas la ville de paris qui
va s'apprêter uniquement sachez que la
ville de paris et celle qui accorde
probablement le moins le moins et que
notamment sur l'autre exemple qui est la
phase tic vous avez dans l'arctique mais
sachez qu'il ya deux cent mille euros
qui n de l'état y avait 3000 euros de la
ville de paris j'aimerais bien qu'on
remette les éléments en place mais vous
avez tout à fait raison c'est toujours
en vie davantage sur la phase iib qu'est
ce qui s'est passé parce que c'est un
petit peu l'histoire qui n'est pas
racontée dans l'article en fait en
novembre 2018 ya eu une interpellation
de monsieur lycia concernant cette
association
une fois que cette interpellation a été
fait et la ville de paris a retiré du
système des délibérations la
délibération qui visait sa subvention la
retirer ça veut dire qu'elle n'a pas été
mise dans le débat elle n'a donc pas été
adopté entre temps qu'est ce qui a été
fait la ville de paris a reçu les
responsables de la phase i qui répondait
à deux interpellations dont une de la
licra attendez je vais jusqu'au bout
avec ses yeux gérard vous ne vous avez
parfaitement raison de dix de nos gîtes
la fasti c'est la fédération des
associations alors des travailleurs
l'hilarité avec tous les immigrés tiens
c'est la base exactement
donc je reprends novembre 2010 huit
interpellations notamment de monsieur
d'issia sur cette association
la ville de paris retire la délibération
du système des délibérations et la
subvention donc mais pas accorder
puisqu'il ya une un système de
d'entretien denquête un petit peu
interne qui est mise en place
ça répond aussi à la licra qui à un
moment donné avait fait un signalement
que fait la ville de paris elle
rencontre les responsables de la fasti
elle rencontre les responsables de la
litra et elle met des légendes ce qu'on
peut appeler une petite enquête interne
pour voir qui était cette association il
rencontre les responsables pour se
mettre d'accord avec ce qu'il y a à la
fois dans l'association qui est une
fédération et avec les actions qui
seront conduites au niveau de la ville
de paris qui vise notamment à aider des
couturiers qui sont installés à la
goutte d'or subventions 3000 euros là
dessus ce que fait la ville de paris
c'est qu'elle adresse en janvier 2019 un
courrier au premier ministre
pourquoi parce que benjamin griveaux
s'était émue de cette subvention à cette
association elle demande aux cons
premier liste quelle est la position de
l'état
la ville de paris réitéra en octobre
2019 le même courrier à l'état qui n'a
toujours pas répondu
la ville de paris voit qu'elle n'est pas
le premier financeur elle est le
tout-petit financeurs le barreau de
paris finance cette association la caf
finance cette association de manière
plus importante encore et la banque de
france sinon cette association ce que je
veux dire c'est que si les autres si les
autres opérateurs avaient fait les mêmes
démarches que la ville de paris ça se
saurait
caf et la ville de paris elle s'est
assurée que ça qu'on veut ce que ça
convenait entre guillemets que les
partis qui concernait la fasti était à
la fois complexe parce qu'une fédération
certains s'exprimer au nom de la
fédération sans avoir le droit de le
faire les représentants de la fédération
était clair par rapport au fait que les
y avait certes une liberté d'expression
pour la fasti mais que celle ci devait
être en cohérence avec l'ordre public et
avec l'ordre républicain et que les lois
en vigueur comme ça a été fait
la subvention a effectivement été passé
et il a même été demandé si l'état
reconduit zèle et a reconduit sachant
que certaines subventions de la ville
sont aussi conditionnée par le fait que
l'état finance d'abord et que la ville
finance après donc tout ça pour vous
dire quoi que vous dire que tel que
s'est présentée c'est pas la ville de
paris qui a aujourd'hui un problème avec
la festi c'est l'état qui n'a toujours
pas répondu au courrier s'agissant de sa
propre position concernant la corde
c'est une association qui est nouvelle
c'est une subvention qui est nouvelle
vous avez dit qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
mentions qui étaient dans ce cas là ce
n'est pas le cas
j'ai été un peu long mais c'est pour
vous dire que le sujet n'est pas
exactement que celui de la ville de
paris qui a fait je crois les démarches
nécessaires pour ce pour vous regardez
comment se positionner effectivement on
aura un sujet parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
que vous avez montré comme élément
concernant la corde effectuera
probablement une saisine de la ville de
paris monsieur alicia pas trop à me le
faire on retirera en l'occurrence la
délibération et comme pour le festi très
facile on fera les démarches en interne
et on demandera aussi à l'état où ça en
est eugénie veste et qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
ça veut dire au delà du cas précis la
mairie de paris je pense qu'un véritable
problème aujourd'hui d'associations qui
en est fait vivre de subsides publics
tout en critiquant le racisme d'état en
affirmant que l'état français est
structurellement raciste il ya ces
citations qui sont cités dans ce papier
mais je pense aussi à william beauté
gela la présidente du parti des
indigènes de la république et salariés
de l'institut du monde arabe depuis 2001
institut du monde arabe qui est qui a
été co fondée par la république
française et des pays arabes et qui
reçoit là aussi des subsides publics
plus ou moins directement donc voila c
est cette hypothèse-là crache sur le
philosémitisme d'état sur le racisme
d'état et en même temps et salariés dans
voilà deux dindes une fondation
subventionnés par l'état
je pense que ça pose un véritable
problème à moi il faut choisir être
cohérent si un racisme d'état ne soyez
pas subventionnés par l'état et par
ailleurs
moi ce que je trouve inquiétant c'est la
progression de cette notion de racisme
d'état
dans ces associations antiracistes qui
autrefois se battait pour 1
on comment dire lutter contre le racisme
de façon universelle en critiquant les
comportements racistes qui pouvait
arriver à tout à chacun et qui
maintenant mettre en état mettant en
question l'état comme si en france il y
avait des lois racistes venir
excusez moi mais depuis depuis depuis 40
ans en france il y a une toute une série
de lois antiracistes
mais j'ai pas vu une seule voire raciste
est le seul exemple qui donne d'ailleurs
ces données dans l'arctique c'est la loi
de 2004 sur les signes religieux à
l'école
donc cette loi était du noir raciste je
rappelle qu'elle est liberticide même
l'ormeau oui et c'est en meilleure forme
et surtout pratique comme si cette fois
cette fois a été faite justement pour
viser tous les signes religieux et non
pas seulement le voile islamique et ça
c'est vraiment problématique parce que
c'est je pense que ce discours porte
énormément notamment chez les
populations jeunes de banlieue ou issus
de l'immigration